call me dude Z dude what okay uh is
there any actual tie between Adam
Sandler and Applebee's that you're aware
of
no a table of dudes in town for a
wedding sent me over a second platter of
chicken tenders how nice is that I went
over and sat with them for a while and
cracked white great group of guys a
busboy getting off his shift was nice
enough to take some pictures for us I
pretended to punch the fellas in their
penises
they pretended to punch me in the penis
these guys got it even the busboy got in
on the action we lifted him over our
heads and opened our mouths under where
his penis was pretending like we were
all trying to suck on his penis or
whatever a bunch of jokers rating five
out of five tenders big Applebee's and a
Big Apple what else could you what kind
of Life buddy